Algún día, un palíndromo
les puede salvar la vida.
En estos tiempos donde
abundan los métodos,
las técnicas y las terapias
para mejorar la salud y el rendimiento,
es extraño que nadie haya reparado aún
en las virtudes de los palíndromos.
Yo les voy a hablar de eso.
Habré tenido unos 7 u 8 años cuando
mi abuela me presentó a los palíndromos.
Me dijo que escriba el nombre de esta
hermosa provincia argentina: [NEUQUÉN]
Y luego me dictó esta famosa frase:
Me dijo que la lea al revés.
"Dábale arroz a la zorra el abad".
No lo podía creer.
Estaba maravillado.
No sabía qué significaba un abad,
ni tenía otra interpretación
para la palabra zorra.
(Risas)
Pero sabía que ahí había magia.
Y esa magia, era la magia de una pasión
que se estaba despertando en mí.
Desde esos tiempos, empecé a leer
todas las palabras hacia atrás.
Y me di cuenta de que estamos
rodeados de palíndromos.
Invisibles hasta ese momento
ante mis ojos.
Luego, empecé a buscar los palíndromos
más ingeniosos que había creados,
y di con frases tan hermosas como:
"Amo la pacífica paloma".
"Nos ideó Edison".
"Yo hago yoga hoy".
(Risas)
O, "La ruta nos aportó
otro paso natural".
Hasta esos tiempos, para mí
crear palíndromos era algo
de genios absolutos.
Cómo los físicos de recién.
O alguna revelación mística.
De ese modo yo explicaba palíndromos
tan perfectos como:
"Eva y Yavé".
O simplemente, "Alá".
Después me di cuenta de que crear
palíndromos lo puede hacer cualquiera.
Y eso lo descubrí en un ascensor
leyendo el botón de la luz,
y descubrí el poético "Luz azul".
Del mismo modo, yendo al baño de un bar,
descubrí el "Soñaba baños".
Desde ese tiempo empecé a crear
mis propios palíndromos.
Empecé con frases como:
"Ánimo de mono me domina".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Luego con pequeños poemitas.
Poemas más complejos.
Historietas ilustradas.
Iba probando formas
hasta que llegué a escribir
un palíndromo súper extenso y complejo
--que era la obsesión que
había tenido desde siempre--
que tiene 6886 palabras,
y que abarca 70 páginas
más o menos en total.
Y fueron 4 meses de completa locura,
que al final terminé sofocado,
con un libro completamente inútil,
y nada popular.
(Risas)
Pero era lo que yo buscaba.
Y yo creo que es aquí
donde está el límite entre
la pasión y la locura.
Porque esto que para la Psiquiatría
puede ser el síntoma de una neurosis,
o para la Economía
la inversión de tiempo útil en
algo completamente improductivo,
(Risas)
para mí significó el conseguir
una meta que yo estaba buscando.
Y yo creo que sea cual sea esa meta,
por más ridícula o absurda que sea,
es donde se define el límite
entre la verdadera pasión
y la simple locura.
Y, por cierto, los palíndromos
son una actividad muy saludable.
Por eso yo ahora les voy a contar
de todos sus beneficios
y les voy a decir por qué algún día
un palíndromo les puede salvar la vida.
Pero antes vamos a pasar por un veloz
recorrido histórico por la palindromía
para darles una idea.
Uno de los primeros antecedentes
es el cuadrado mágico en algunas
ruinas romanas de Europa.
Que además de ser bidireccional,
tiene otra dirección vertical.
Esto le ha dado el nombre
de "cuadrado mágico".
Y además se le han hecho interpretaciones
numerológicas, cabalísticas,
y hasta religiosas.
Vinculados siempre a la magia,
los palíndromos.
Luego a lo largo de los siglos,
encontramos algunos palíndromos dispersos
como este latino inscripto
en algunas iglesias de Europa.
Este griego, también, inscripto
en iglesias de Europa.
Uno latino atribuido a Dante Alighieri.
Uno en italiano a Miguel Ángel.
Y así llegamos al siglo XX, donde
la palindromía empieza a florecer.
Primero, de la mano de escritores
consagrados como James Joyce,
en habla inglesa.
Y, en nuestro idioma, nuestro
compatriota Juan Filloy.
Uno de los primeros
coleccionistas y teóricos
de la palindromía.
El mexicano Augusto Monterroso
en un capítulo llamado "Onis es asesino"
de uno de sus libros.
Nuestro querido Julio Cortázar,
en un cuento "Lejana",
nombra 4 palíndromos
que ya él los hizo famosos.
Y el venezolano Darío Lancini,
que en su libro "Oír a Darío",
empieza con los primeros poemas
y producciones literarias palindrómicas.
Y así llegamos a finales del siglo XX,
con el Club Palindromista
Internacional (CPI),
donde un grupo de
intelectuales lúdicos
y un poco excéntricos,
se juntan a compartir palíndromos.
Y editan una revista desde el año 87
hasta la misma fecha de hoy,
dedicada a los palíndromos.
Como se imaginarán
cuando conocí a este grupo,
para mí fue una felicidad tremenda.
Por primera vez conocía a alguien
que podía compartir
esta pasión excéntrica conmigo.
Y fue una prueba de que
tan loco no estaba.
Y ahora empieza, al decir
de mi amigo Pedro Ruiz,
la Era de Oro de los palíndromos.
Porque hay, a pesar de que
la gente ni conozca la palabra,
miles de palíndromos en el mundo
de todos tamaños, de todas formas.
Palindromistas en todos los países,
y se ha iniciado una
ola de publicaciones
palindrómicas con el objetivo
de jerarquizar este arte.
Y con ese objetivo, en 2009 iniciamos
el movimiento literario palindrómico
REVER.
Que el objetivo es, hacer que el
palíndromo deje de ser un simple juego,
y se lo considere una forma literaria.
Una verdadera composición literaria.
Y de ese modo,
la palindromía llega en este 2013 a TEDx,
y yo me propongo demostrarles que
además de un juego y de
una composición literaria,
tiene que ser considerado un
método de entrenamiento mental.
Por eso les voy a contar
10 de sus beneficios,
para nuestra salud mental.
Y finalmente les voy a decir:
por qué un palíndromo algún día
les puede salvar la vida.
La experiencia palindrómica es
una experiencia muy particular.
Una mezcla entre hacer crucigramas
y escribir poesías.
Un juego y una
búsqueda de sentido.
Además, el palíndromo
es una obra activa
porque está implicada
en su propia creación.
Mientras uno escribe de un lado,
el palíndromo se autoescribe del otro.
Esto da particularidades muy interesantes,
y beneficios a nuestra salud intelectual.
Por ejemplo,
ejercita holísticamente el cerebro.
Este es el primero de los beneficios.
Una vez en una presentación una maestra
me dijo que le interesaban los palíndromos
porque trabajaba con personas
con Alzheimer.
Como todo juego de ingenio,
ejercita la lógica del cerebro.
Pero el palíndromo va más allá,
porque la simetría ejercita la
intelectualidad del hemisferio izquierdo,
pero la búsqueda de sentido,
la intuición del hemisferio derecho.
Por eso es una ejercitación holística
en un mismo ejercicio.
Estimula la sorpresa y la creatividad.
Nunca sabemos cómo va a
terminar un palíndromo.
Y eso nos conecta con la creatividad
que todos tenemos dentro.
Nos conecta con el juego y la risa.
Porque es un juego que
lo hacemos seriamente,
y entendemos que siempre podemos
darle un sentido lúdico a la vida.
Y siempre nos regala una sonrisa
por más que no sea gracioso.
Nos revela la importancia
de lo insignificante.
Porque cada letra en un palíndromo
es fundamental.
Y ahí entendemos el valor
de las pequeñas cosas.
Promueve el cambio de enfoque.
Porque empezamos
a escribir un palíndromo,
y del otro lado nos aparece
algo completamente distinto.
Si escribimos Amor, aparece Roma.
Entonces de un enfoque amoroso
pasamos a uno histórico.
Y, así, inevitablemente tenemos
que estar cambiando de enfoque
y buscando soluciones alternativas.
Nos despierta habilidades dormidas.
Nos exige un pensamiento
tan complejo a veces que
despierta habilidades que ni nosotros
sabíamos que realmente teníamos.
Nos induce a la búsqueda
del equilibrio.
Porque el palíndromo básicamente es
equilibrar el sentido de los 2 extremos.
Y esto, inmediatamente,
lo llevamos a la vida.
Nos amiga con el fracaso.
Porque de 100 palíndromos que empezamos,
uno probablemente llegue
a un fin satisfactorio.
En este sentido del fracaso
deja de ser un fantasma,
y empieza a ser un tramo inevitable
en el camino al éxito.
Ejercita la flexibilidad y la adaptación
en la búsqueda de objetivos.
Porque nos enseña cuándo tenemos
que acatar las circunstancias,
de las leyes que son muy rígidas,
y cuándo atacar para llegar
inevitablemente al palíndromo.
Porque sin esa convicción,
terminamos diciendo:
¡Es imposible hacer palíndromos!
--que no lo es--
Y finalmente,
nos ofrece respuestas
a dudas existenciales.
Porque como dije, el palíndromo
siempre nos sorprende,
y está vinculado
a un aire de magia.
En este sentido,
lo podemos usar como un oráculo
para preguntar sobre dudas
existenciales de nuestras vidas.
Por ejemplo, cuando mi amigo Cristian
me dijo si podía venir acá,
como era un poco complicado
acudí a la palindromancia.
Y encontré: "Acude y educa".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Inevitablemente tuve que responder:
¡Yo voy!
(Risas)
Pero del mismo modo,
y que es lo que nos trae acá,
para ir concluyendo,
podemos apelar para preguntar
sobre el sentido de la vida.
Y la pregunta por el sentido es
siempre una pregunta por el Ser.
En este camino, la búsqueda
de la propia pasión,
que está llena de dudas
y de obstáculos.
¿Debemos ser lo que se nos impone?
Personas adaptadas,
normales, productivas,
o ¿ser lo que realmente somos?
En este punto, el palíndromo
es inflexible.
Y las respuestas son contundentes:
"Se es o no se es".
(Risas)
"Somos o no somos".
Y por si les queda alguna duda,
insiste,
"Sos o no sos".
(Risas)
Así podemos ver que los palíndromos
nos enseñan que no hay escapatoria.
Debemos asumir lo que somos,
enfrentar nuestra pasión por más absurda
o extravagante que pueda llegar a ser.
Y, con convicción,
pararnos frente al mundo
y decir:
"YO SOY"
Soy lo que busco, soy lo que elijo,
soy lo que quiero.
Simplemente, yo soy.
(Aplausos)
Para finalizar,
les tengo que decir,
no me he olvidado,
¡por qué algún día un palíndromo
les puede salvar la vida!
Imagínense si se pierden
en un desierto inexplorado,
o en alguna isla desierta.
Un palíndromo [S.O.S.]
¡les puede salvar la vida!
(Aplausos)